[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
okay something that is wrong and so far
there have been many challengers no
winners nobody's been able to catch us
so far well tonight a fan named waheed
from vancouver
thinks he caught a mistake he says it
happened during a recent video piece
that we did uh that involved stephen
tyler
hi german this is wahid from vancouver
um it's about your show where you bombed
you know steven tyler i mean you know
that was fantastic
very good idea but
dude this is what you did
[Applause]
that's the passenger really you couldn't
find like a fighter airplane best thing
that that plane can do it like drop
luggage
come on man
bat cone bad color
do this like bad cones did bad conan
like you were a dog that had missed the
papers yeah
no one's talked to me like that since my
father four days ago
well i'm sorry waiheed you are dead
wrong now true that was a passenger
plane but it was a bomber passenger
plane
now i don't blame you for never having
heard of these top secret planes known
only by the faa the pentagon and myself
but they do exist don't just take my
word watch this footage from that very
flight over gillette stadium
hello everyone this is your captain
speaking we are right now passing over
an absolute butchering of the national
anthem by stephen tyler it's uh just
awful so i'm gonna ask you to go ahead
and take out your under seat bombs and
let them fly thank you very much
[Music]
that proves it if nothing else does by
the way uh i usually i have a tendency
to make fun of the person who sends in a
correction
uh but why he you seem like a nice
normal guy so i'm not going to do that
what's that
oh i'm just being told that wahid you
added something at the end of your video
that you probably didn't think we were
going to show on tv
let's take a look you know i can do like
you know monkey
i can do monkey very well
he's good
well i had correction that's an ape
waheed yeah
yes
up top
[Applause]
[Music]
so the challenge still stands if you
think you spotted an error on our show
report at teamcoco.com
haha i found an error we will sort it
out right here on the air let's see if
you've got what it takes to make chump
meat out of the maestro we'll take a
break we'll be right back